all right so I just finished the entire
series of Battlestar Galactica and I
have the urge to reformat my cuss words
I have no frakkin idea why and if you
haven't seen Battlestar Galactica yet
just do yourself a favor and watch it
but I noticed they cuss differently in
Battlestar Galactica than we do in
particular they say gods damn it they
say the plural not the singular because
they're polytheists they would do that
they believe in multiple gods but then I
noticed there are people in our world
they don't believe in God but they still
say god damn it it's still a cuss word
and I find that interesting because it
proves that cussing is not subjective to
what you believe and it totally should
be like the monotheistic curse word
would be god damn it a singular
polytheists would be gods damn it plural
I don't think it would stop there like
agnostics I don't know damn it atheists
nothing damn it Scientologists
Battlefield Earth damn it or is that Tom
Cruise damn it and then there's a belief
of Chi energy the life force within
you're the master of your own destiny
in which case me damn it myself damn it
or I damn it are all perfectly
acceptable cuss words and what about
Jesus Jesus Christ a name and a title
which is also a cuss word but I mean do
Buddhists say Buddha when they're pissed
I mean could you really imagine someone
getting so frustrated they're like Oh
Buddha they're making Smurfs in 3d I
mean really think about the applications
it'd just be like Zeus's beard dude
you're making me so mad right now that
filters damn it man do can you not say
those words
Tom Cruise so don't do that then you got
to think what makes the cuss word with
someone just like another cuss word what
about [ __ ] that is a cuss word why I
don't know what about the big one the
King the f-word [ __ ] is a cuss word
Frick not a cuss word even though people
use it as some sort of freaking
substitute see alright then I'd argue
what about [ __ ] Fu K missing the C
spelled differently can use it as a
substitute but it's not really a cuss
word ah I mean can you just make up cuss
words out of thin air like phrases like
going green or the Shocker Wiimote is
now my personal cuss word sorry Nintendo
it's mine now that [ __ ] will stick
strike that that Wiimote will stick then
again if cussing were subjective and
really limit what you could say on TV
just beard dude you're making me so mad
right now
Chris dammit man do can you not say
those words I said don't do that I need
to know who has gone on Wikipedia or
Google or whatever and found out where
cuss words come from where do they come
from and what makes a customer to cuss
word these are the things that plagued
my mind but if you like what you've seen
here
want to see more click right here to see
more